in the history of animation which dates
back to the earliest years of film
itself there are two figures whose
contributions to our artform place them
above all others
the first is Walt Disney the second is
Hayao Miyazaki
in Japan Miyazaki Nissan is considered a
national treasure unquestionably the
most respected and important figure in
Japanese cinema today four of his films
ranked among the top 10 highest-grossing
feature films of all time in Japan
that's not just animated films but all
films which includes the Academy
award-winning spirited way the highest
grossing film of all time of Japan but
it's not the success that has so
profoundly affected animators filmmakers
and audiences around the world
it's the artistry of his films that has
I feel extremely lucky to have been
living and working during these Miyazaki
sons career to have been able to watch
and learn from his films as they have
been released they have moved me they
have inspired me and they have helped
shape me as a filmmaker in 1979 I just
graduated from Cal arts and was working
as an animator at the Disney Studios and
what I and my fellow Cal arts grads had
found was that the entire movie
moviemaking industry all of the studio's
even Disney had fallen into the belief
that animation was just for children my
peers and I tried to convince our bosses
that this wasn't true but we were shut
down at every turn this was very
discouraging to say the least
then I saw a movie from Japan that
changed my life Lupin the third castle
of Cagliostro it was Heil Miyazaki's
first film
I was totally blown away by this movie
castle of Cagliostro had adventure heart
action and humor done with such style
and sophistication and a wonderful eye
for the details of human behavior it was
proof positive as Walt Disney had shown
so many years before that animation
truly was for everyone you see I
actually was so impressed by this film
that I even wooed my wife Nancy with it
I showed her scenes from the film the
day after I met her true story it was
love at first sight it was love at first
sight but I just wanted to make sure and
thank God she loved the movie I know
that sounds really geeky but but hey 26
years and five sons later I'm proud to
say it really worked
animation is such a labor-intensive
artform every detail from a blink of an
eye to the tiniest gust of wind has to
be created painstakingly planned and
then crafted by hand frame by frame an
animated feature takes on average about
four years to create miyazaki Sanh has
directed eleven feature films more than
any other animation director in history
not only did he write as well as direct
those eleven movies he also drew all of
the storyboards every single drawing for
each film himself and every film he has
created is a masterpiece my neighbor
totoro Porco Rosa Porco Rosso Princess
Mononoke in spirited away to name just a
few
each film is full of ideas images in
emotions that are so immensely creative
that it's hard to conceive that one man
thought of them all
every time I watched miyazaki movie i
learned something new about the craft of
filmmaking miyazaki sun is the most
original filmmaker ever to work in our
medium an artist of incredible
sensitivity envisioned his films are
made with such heart and skill and
nobility of intent they gently and
piercingly awaken in their viewers a
passionate appreciation of the simple
and profound gifts we are given in our
lives from the beauty of the natural
world to the opportunities we have to
use our talents for the benefit of
others il Miyazaki has deeply influenced
animation for ever inspiring generations
of artists to work in our medium and
illuminating its limitless potential his
films are gifts to everyone who loves
the cinema and they would be watched and
cherished
as long as movies exist in stature in
influence in the range and quality of
his body of work there will be there
will never be another to rival him